college bowl season is quickly
approaching and one of the biggest games
happens in our own backyard the las
vegas bowl they're sponsoring this next
segment and here to tell us all about it
is john cecente the executive director
of espn events with the las vegas bowl
good to see you john good to see you
buddy so this is the 30th year of the
game but it's kind of a whole brand new
setup this year tell us what's going on
it is and everything that everything
that we do to promote the game we talk
about new matchup new house new date and
uh the new matchup we now have pac-12
number two versus big ten number three
wow which is uh which puts us in a tier
one cut type bowl game new house which
is at allegion stadium moving over from
sam boyd stadium which we will not miss
and uh a new date we've always been a
pre-christmas game to drive tourism to
the destination the week before
christmas we're now moving to a
post-christmas game on december 30th
that's huge and i was reading that this
bowl game is as out of all the ball
games is like the 16th oldest ball game
it's been around for quite some time
yeah it's crazy to think that that when
the when the game started in 1992 and
there were 16 games they said there's
too many there's too many no more um and
now here we are in into the 40s with
with bowl games but you know what it
provides the student athletes with great
great memorable experiences it brings
them to destinations that they normally
wouldn't go to and so it's it's a
win-win for everybody and this is just
not a one-game deal there's festivities
taking place all week what's happening
prior to the game what happens after the
game yeah the the going joke with with
me and all my friends and everybody
around they're like you work one day a
year what are you doing for the rest of
the year which can't be the best game in
the valley
it can't be any further from the truth i
mean we have 16 events just during bowl
week alone to showcase the destination
make sure that when the kids are here
they're having a good time make sure
that everybody across the country sees
what's happening in vegas and then
throughout the year it's it's working
with
non-profit community outreach groups
youth football groups to make sure that
you know we're being great community
partners in our own backyard and let's
touch on that because yeah it is one big
game during the year but you guys are
doing stuff all throughout the valley
throughout the entire year what are some
of the things that you guys do
well we work with youth football we work
with goody two-shoes opportunity village
make-a-wish um to try to give back to
our community um we host events
throughout the year that again
showcasing the destination to the folks
that that are in the college football
landscape and it's planning for the 16
events during bowl week so all of a
sudden the year flies by on you out of
nowhere and and here we are already in
the thick of it well busy season is
coming up you do you know you mentioned
that the two divisions you know for the
front rider right now what teams we're
looking at no but uh on the big ten side
we're looking at teams like penn state
wisconsin iowa purdue
on the pac-12 side it's teams like
arizona state utah ucla so we're in a
good position the games the game's going
in the right direction the matchup is
starting to take shape with really good
teams and and we're excited for the next
46 days
until we get there it's gonna be
exciting too at allegiant stadiums can
we buy tickets now when we start buying
tickets for the game they've been on
sale since july we've already sold 37
000 tickets holy smokes to a game that i
can't tell you who's playing until
december 5th so that's good there's 22
000 tickets left right now so if you do
want to see great college football at
allegion stadium uh lvbol.com is the
best place to get it and uh so you've
been obviously been to a legion stadium
right yeah a few times yeah a few times
right so it's an experience too this is
a great event for the entire family to
go check out absolutely and listen we we
find that sweet spot right between the
raiders and and unlv right it's great
college football um it's affordable
college football and uh and you get to
you get to see our brand new two billion
dollar toy it's gonna be awesome john
thank you so much for joining us
appreciate everybody give me a hand
right there yeah john and i will palace
we go back to our college days at unlv
that's a whole other segment though
talking about yeah nicknames and
everything yep oh yeah thank you to espn
productions for sponsoring this segment
for more information on the las vegas
bowl visit lvbowl.com
so up next